[Music]
all right in high-standard news yep
submitted by water sucks
I hope you dehydrate and die okay all
right the internet shames a mom after
she posts her requirements for her
babysitter's shamed that's it
what did they have to buy perfectly tan
like six foot two broad shoulders or
some [ __ ] like that
Oh like men yeah man there's a mom post
and probably there are 14 requirements
what are the 14 can I see nine-inch dick
looking for a babysitter in the area P
and me if your interest must have blue
eyes
here are my requirements number one have
a bachelor's degree in child care or
nine years of relevant babysitting 9y
with that one right I'm fine with that
well actually it's a green child yeah I
was like there's a child of the Bona
yeah but I've never heard of a
bachelor's and I don't care it's some
kind of thing you know whatever that I
still think you know about kids be smart
Yeah right number two three good
references with phone numbers that's
fine that's nice I love that one nervous
normal full-time available availability
including weekends that's another normal
one I guess yeah that's like a full-time
nanny yes the job yeah number four your
own car and driver license I think those
two go hand-in-hand I'm wait to say
though even working at Target they ask
you like you have a car that works
there's ten more number five native
english-speaking and preferred second
language to teach my children
horn Annie the babysitter isn't getting
Wednesday's shame worthy we're not here
yet yeah it gets crazy okay number six
CPR certified ideally a CNA license this
fine nurse assistant okay this is
getting really hard to find a lot of
money for this you know they're saying
that the same it's well they say the $12
an hour
yeah it's getting more specifics up to
pay matches with the more certifications
and degrees and all that yeah number
seven no history of traffic tickets and
no problems with the law sir we'll be
running your name through databases fair
that's fair number eight no tattoos no
drugs no alcohol no sketchy social media
behavior and or public photos okay [ __ ]
you that's none of your business
yeah yeah so your business you know I
mean so that's the way that's my
business but I get I guess if you're
like you know if you're trying to say
you don't cuz you don't want your kid
influenced by like wanting to get a
tattoo whatever but in this day and age
you can't hide I'd say you can't hide
everything from your kid with social
media the TV and everything like that so
that was a little bit like alright I
just feel like this list is just gonna
end up as I must attend Hogwarts School
of wizardry like you just get crazier
crazyer it's getting there I think the
no drug use is pretty reasonable that
one is but attached to normal drug use
if on personal time that's their own
thing no no I like what the kids I just
don't think that that should be I don't
think that they should be in the same
line it shouldn't say no tattoos no
drugs no alcohol no sketchy social media
behavior all that [ __ ] is not linked
alright it's not linked that should be
individual things if you want to say I
don't want any visible tattoos that's
fine because there are jobs that say
okay there's straightedge people who
have tattoos yeah but it shouldn't be
like that no drugs that should be his
own thing no drugs and alcohol should be
its own thing I'm with you on that's
like saying no drugs in Hawaiian shirt
each other but I'm also with no sketchy
social media behavior I mean in this day
and age that's gonna be a new thing I'm
actually not opposed to that one either
you want your kid you know you're
working with my kid and then you like
you know you have like a bunch of titty
pics on the on Twitter or you have like
you know whatever you're thinking you
have some like weird things on the
Internet
I guess you might want to be like I
don't want my kid around that I mean I
guess but the one that the tattoo one
shouldn't be in there have to want to
take offense to it I don't even have
tattoos but I take offense that
somebody's putting tattoos with drugs
and alcohol yeah you know I mean number
nine
must be okay with my two pit bulls fair
that's normal you don't want then they
give you
freak them out I mean we could be
allergic to dogs number 10 must be okay
with emergency last minute calls okay I
get that number 11 perfect attendance
100% required
yeah that's any job this is getting
weird now because like announced to the
point of you're not looking for it
you're looking for a nanny so do you
have a quarters for this place to live
in yeah exactly like live-in nanny for a
really rich person are you paying this
person like 50 bucks an hour right now
number 12
willing to pay for some snacks okay hold
on out of her old that's weird
the weird one that's weird number 13
we'll love to work with an infant
three-year-olds and five-year-olds well
that's the whole point of this anyway
number 14 ideally will be a Trump fan
annex what the [ __ ] yeah this is the
final part in exchange I will be
offering $10 an hour under the table
cash it's like making $15 an hour
normally but without paying text that's
not even worth $15 an hour only by the
way we're gonna tax together yeah so
this is found on Facebook and it's gotta
be a joke sit it on the subreddit
choosing beggars and that's where it
went viral
picky beggars are the worst if this
person was like a millionaire and they
were they were giving like top not a
six-figure income for a stay-at-home
nanny that makes sense yeah this person
is smarter than the person putting this
ad up even qualified to be that loved it
yeah I don't I don't know about that and
even with the thing with the Trump thing
I don't even mind that if you're saying
like look I have I am I'm conservative
yeah and this is the things we're gonna
be talking about in our house like I
don't want you putting your liberal
agenda on my kids and that's your thing
then III think that's fair - yeah
they're like this [ __ ] is looking for a
slave I mean I think the most offensive
part is the $10 an hour thing and you
have to pay for your own snacks yeah
next into $10 so they were saying like I
thought they meant
I thought she meant she'd be willing to
pay for the babysitter snacks I was like
well I guess that's nice then I realized
she meant the babysitter's will be
paying for snacks this Beach is delusion
but not even she would be pretty much
doing work for free I call these people
tomato people because these are the ones
that need a tomato throw in their face
somebody they want they want their cake
you needed to yeah you know I want a
super qualified babysitter that I can
get for cheap go [ __ ] yourself like and
get this I'm gonna give you $10 untaxed
[ __ ] so southern person what kind of
[ __ ] idiot will take it this other
person responded with I've seen these
ads before in NYC but they'll pay you 60
to 80 K and other perks eventually you
get paid to raise someone else's kid
yeah and even that doesn't seem like
enough considering that like your whole
life is like taken over it to be
available 24 hours do you to pay for
[ __ ] like that yeah that's like personal
assistance live-in maids nannies all
that not only do they get like a good
pay they also get a lot of gifts from
the rich family and they get a lot of
[ __ ] and they get to live there for
free and they live there for that was
crazy talk
yes although one says the kids will be
87 90 and 92 by the time she gets an
inquiry exactly that's [ __ ] crazy
where do these people come this would
have been okay if half of those
requirements were in the verbal
interview like if you just listed some
of the normal things and then after
you're left or just by the way like once
you have that I really do have a tattoo
you know what I'm okay with all that
list yeah do you think the two things
I'm not okay with is to pay and the
snacks because they go hand in here yeah
yeah yeah
not gonna pay you and out of that $10
you need to buy some snacks [ __ ] you
what a demanding person you know
also nine years of experience is so
specific to it like why nine she
basically said I need you to have a
master's in babysitting like what the
[ __ ] is that masters and babysitting you
[ __ ] weirdo yeah the funny thing is
she wants a CNA plus someone with a
bachelor's degree and only pay them ten
bucks an hour
yeah and be available 24 hours a day for
awesome for emergency phone calls and be
a teacher because you're teaching you're
their child another language teacher the
food and you can't have a social life
yeah and if you do don't be drinking and
you gotta be Cesar Millan with the two
pitbulls
yeah we're trying to eat the snacks you
know I mean you got a baby and you got
like you know and then you have to also
be like you have to be like yeah make
America great again hat on and say it
sounds terrible sweet it's big kids for
ten bucks an hour don't take charge
perfect yeah alright when you do
babysitting it's French so it's three
dollars again we're looking for Batman
[Laughter]
let's have a secret lair yeah with
plenty of equipment to handle crime was
the British Butler she wants Mary
Poppins and Alfred at once all right
damn have you ever watched those nanny
shows I love there's always have like a
mean british lady come in yeah it's like
an American family yeah they start
crying and [ __ ] but then they like whip
them into shape
yeah it's like bar rescue yeah but kids
yeah if you guys didn't have your family
helping would you get hire a nanny I
think we would have to no choice yeah we
don't have a choice
no I mean maybe cuz I thought maybe you
can like rearrange your work life to the
point where you would take
take good uh I mean if it was like right
now that'd be really hard and I would
have to get I would have to get a
babysitter all right honey you think it
would change if when you get your second
kid uh what would change that I would
want to stay or that I would get any
like because right now your mom's
helping a lot so it should be hadn't
beat handling - I would that would
change for sure because then I would
have to be there too because just Tiger
right now by himself I'm like he's
already Carly because he's walking and
he's getting into [ __ ] and what the
handcuff technique just handcuff um
system doesn't go anywhere that's true
you can get like bars like a like a jail
you know and but it won't be a joke
who'd be colorful yeah that's what we
have right now handcuff em to the bar
yeah yeah no it would it'll be like a
Rubik's Cube you know like you have to
figure out how to get out of it if you
want something you gotta get out of here
googling how do you get out of my anyone
complains it's an escape room it's he
loves stimulating is much yeah it's a
puzzle
[Music]